Hmm.
That's an Obama administration has
brought about change.
I don't think that can be debated.
There is everything from the symbolic to
the substantive,
you know,
levels of what it would mean to have an
African American president.
And,
uh,
I think at the same time,
there have been changes that were
unanticipated,
that came as a consequence of his
presidency.
And so when we talk about
the initial moment of his launch,
uh,
into as a national political figure,
which was in that 2004 speech convention
speech in Boston,
uh,
he began that by saying,
you know,
there's not a black America or white
America or a Latino America,
but there's the United States of
America.
And you know,
that was entirely untrue.
You know,
they were vastly different realities
that very often corresponded to race,
or at least were significantly
correlated with race and ethnicity.
And so,
uh,
what we've seen over the course of his
two terms has been a
means by which our period in which it's
been increasingly visible.
You know,
the distinctions that we see,
um,
as citizens based upon these elements of
identity,
who we are.
And,
uh,
where we're from and what kind of
communities we live in.
And you know,
what are racial ethnic background is,
those things would come to the
foreground.
And I don't think that you could
possibly have anticipated the extent to
which they have done so.
And so when we look at,
you know,
black lives matter and how it emerged,
uh,
one,
it seemed kind of paradoxical that for,
you know,
half a century African Americans had
been struggling,
uh,
specifically around the voting rights
act to get increased political electoral
representation.
And at the point at which,
uh,
were represented at the pinnacle of
American political power,
it reverberates and this kind of a
boomerang effect.
And we wound up with a revitalized
grassroots movement of people who don't
necessarily trust political power,
people who are outside the
establishment,
uh,
and people who were attempting to kind
of move the levers of political power to
the advantage of a disempowered
communities.
And one would have thought,
I guess in a kind of naive perspective
on Barack Obama's presidency,
you would have thought that those things
would not have been necessarily,
would not have been necessary.
Certainly some of his critics,
uh,
bought that he was going to govern in
such a radical way that,
uh,
it was going to be,
you know,
reparations handed out in the first week
for African Americans.
Uh,
and he's been very moderate and centrist
and,
and often reluctant to directly engage
issues of race.
I think that's what some of frustration
who come from the younger generation of
activists,
uh,
and they took his moderation as being,
in some instances inadequate to the task
at hand.
I think that there's a lot that's
missing from the public conversation
about race.
When we talk about race,
we most often confronted as an emotional
reality,
uh,
or this kind of
subject of,
um,
social anxiety or something in which we
go,
oh,
you know,
we're really all the same and you know,
it's a ridiculous idea that we separate
ourselves in this way.
Uh,
which is true,
but it's also very facile way of
approaching that question because on a
more fundamental level,
race is a mythology.
But there's also a very useful myth.
And that's the only way it's been able
to endure for as long as it has,
particularly in the United States.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
what I mean by that is we look at things
now when we talk about race,
pretend to say that
no,
there's this level of mistrust or their
stereotypes or misunderstandings.
And you know,
we have these problems and we should all
just look at each other as humans.
But the fact of the matter is that
things like slavery and segregation and
economic discrimination,
these things happened willfully.
They weren't the result of a kind of
haphazard,
mistaken approaches to people who happen
to be different from you.
And so it means that we don't simply
have to dispel mythology.
It means we have to actually grapple
with people having concrete interests
that may be different than the interests
of other communities.
And so it's not simply implicit bias in
policing that has resulted in
disproportionate numbers as we saw in
Ferguson.
It wasn't simply a matter of implicit
bias or stereotypes,
or,
um,
good intentioned,
well intentioned individuals who
happened to have arrested or pulled over
more African Americans and whites.
We saw that there was an institutional
structural approach to particular
communities that were being fleeced by a
police department.
And so we can find those kinds of
dynamics again and again and again.
And so when we talk about race,
it's going to be much more intractable
than simply ridding ourselves of,
uh,
maybe some,
mistaken ideas that have rattled around
in our heads.
So sometime.